PRESENTER 1: I want to know
whether we can teach design
thinking to a group
of non-designers,
and innovative in
the education system.
PRESENTER 2: It's
a two day workshop
where we are learning about
design thinking in order
to solve real world
education problems.
PRESENTER 3: So
prototypes, like a sketch,
they're just a
representation of an idea.
PRESENTER 4: And when we
think about innovation,
it's both a
technological innovation,
but it also needs
to be innovation
around teamwork and
professional ed communities
and thinking together.
PRESENTER 5: How can we
re-imagine what a school should
be in the 21st century?
PRESENTER 6: We have empathy
building community service.
PRESENTER 5: What is the
role of online learning?
What is the role
of collaboration?
PRESENTER 7: So just discuss
and vote if we need to.
PRESENTER 8: How
would we come together
as people from very
diverse backgrounds
and think about
solutions for education?
PRESENTER 9: And we have
professors, teachers, students,
children.
We have policymakers.
PRESENTER 5: The stakes are
changing so fast that educators
have not been able to keep up.
PRESENTER 10: When you can
break it down and tell it
to a five-year-old
or a 10-year-old,
like the ones that
we have here today,
then that is when you
really know your material.
We had specific
workshop modules.
I would teach them
a thing or two.
They would go back into their
teams and implement that.
PRESENTER 2: It's a really
interactive process.
It's a very proactive process.
It really forces you to think
in ways that you may not
have thought before.
PRESENTER 11: Because
if you have TV--
PRESENTER 5: Design
thinking is really
a kind of blending of
the scientific method
and the creative process.
PRESENTER 9: And we're
going to have things inside.
PRESENTER 12: What's great
about it is they really
breakdown to these such
simple actionable steps.
PRESENTER 13: Starts
with some brainstorming,
goes through some
iterations of like, OK,
can we narrow down
all these ideas
that we're coming up with?
PRESENTER 5: So you have
a kind of observation,
empathy, research, try to
frame the problem, work
through a series
of prototypes which
are equivalent to
the experimentation.
And then test those results
and see if they match up
with the hypothesis.
PRESENTER 14: [LAUGHS]
Oh, that's awesome.
PRESENTER 2: We are pitching
an online advising platforms
for students in lower income
neighborhoods who may or may
not have access to quality
counseling and career and life
advice services.
PRESENTER 15: There's this
huge interest in food trucks
and science trucks.
And a space where you could
track where it is and you could
rate it.
How many of you have ever
eaten at a food truck?
PRESENTER 5: Everything that
we've been doing in two days
is going to be reduced
to two minutes.
PRESENTER 15: For people
using and learning
from these educational mobile
trucks, you need to know,
what will you learn?
What's the value of
learning this way?
And what are reliable reviews
of the best trucks out there?
AUDIENCE: So are you considering
any ed service as a truck?
PRESENTER 15: We're sort
of anticipating a market
for ed mobile trucks, but--
PRESENTER 10: The prizes
are reimbursable stipends
for your project development.
Is the innovation creative?
Is it feasible?
Does it includes
multiple perspectives?
PRESENTER 16: It's a place
where teachers, students,
and professionals who are
living in the community--
STUDENT: I'm hoping we win
because I would like to be
the youngest entrepreneur ever.
That would be fun.
PRESENTER 17: You all
uncovered some big themes.
The need to collaborate.
PRESENTER 18: I like
how much every group
got a real good handle
on the design process.
PRESENTER 19: I thought
the energy was great.
I really enjoyed the creativity.
PRESENTER 20: And I am
a convert to trucks.
I mean, I love food trucks,
but there are so many trucks.
So basically, there are
mobile, physical things
that are going to
happen in education.
I learned that this afternoon.
Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]